nous sommes au Commissariat à l'énergie
atomique de Saclay et voici Gilles
Rammstein Paléo climatologue depuis des
années avec son équipe il met au point
des modèles informatiques qui racontent
trois avenir possible en fait tout
dépend de nous de la manière dont nous
continuerons ou pas à perturber le
climat en rejetant du casque carbonique
dans l'atmosphère pour commencer le
premier scénario et bien sûr utopique il
suppose que l'humanité dans sa grande
sagesse arrête immédiatement les dégâts
dans ce cas le cycle des glaciations se
déroule normalement
la prochaine qu'on peut le voir commence
dans 50 000 ans pour culminer dans
150.000 ans
le second scénario plus réaliste imagine
une perturbation du climat importante
mais non massive
premier constat la calotte du Groenland
supporte mal cette situation et fond en
grande partie et puis on attend le temps
défile et on voit que rien ne se passe à
50000 ans alors qu'on doit avoir une
poussée glaciaire absolument rien à
150000 ans on devrait être pas oxygène
glaciaire absolument rien et il faut
attendre 220 000 ans pour que une
nouvelle poussée glaciaire commence et
quelle augmente jusqu'à atteindre son
paroxysme à peu près 100 000 ans après
enfin troisième scénario l'homme ne fait
aucun effort pour limiter les rejets de
gaz carbonique dans l'atmosphère
et cette fois dès le début de la
simulation le Groenland disparaît
les choses plus extraordinaires encore
dans cette simulation c'est que pas de
pousser de glacière à 50 000 ans pas
plus à 150000 rien à 220 000 et en fait
rien du tout sur les 300.000 ans de la
simulation
vous avez même raison
les mêmes provoquer le réchauffement
climatique nous éviterons peut-être la
prochaine glaciation alors on ne sait
plus quoi penser faut-il le déplorer
faut-il s'en réjouir après tout du moins
a priori cela semble être une bonne
nouvelle
c'est sans doute à une très bonne
nouvelle pour notre 300.000 ans mais
pour l'immédiat et pour en arriver là il
faudra perturber le système
environnemental tellement fort avec une
planète qui comporte 7 milliards
d'hommes que ce sera l'Enfer tout de
suite pour un hypothétique bonheur dans
300.000 ans je suis pas sûr que ce soit
le bon choix à faire
mais nous ne sommes pas encore là pour
l'heure ne perdons pas de vue que la
Terre est une planète avant d'être notre
maison sa logique et celle d'une planète
et ce n'est pas la nôtre